comment relancer l'économie de montréal
une grande étude dévoilée par bmo groupe
financier le boston consulting group
suggère de s'inspirer de cette ville qui
ont relevé le défi
malgré les difficultés économiques
françois cormier elles sont sept 7
villes comparables à montréal qui ont su
se relever
melbourne en australie manchester en
angleterre et les villes américaines de
boston pittsburgh philadelphie seattle
et san diego
faudrait-il s'inspirer de leur succès
oui selon les auteurs d'une nouvelle
étude
mais les villes qui entourent montréal
devront participer à l'opération
important il sentit s'unissent pénalité
ici on atteint 89 amène nombre de
fumerie mois nous parce qu'autant à
philadelphie par exemple c'est le maire
ed rendell qui a été le sauveur de la
ville des auteurs de l'étude sont
formels montréal a besoin d'un
leadership fort pittsburgh
elle a reçu un gros coup de main de
l'état de la pennsylvanie
la relance de montréal se fera si les
gouvernements supérieurs
donc québec et ottawa s'impliquent jeu
point fiscalisme je comprends que c'est
toujours la même poche qui payent donc
faut pas que ça soit juste un changement
de main pour enlever dans post un autre
montréal doit aussi diminuer sa
dépendance aux taxes municipales trouver
d'autres sources de revenus peut faire
nos fils quand deux jeunes familles qui
veulent rester à montréal et tenant san
diego a misé sur les affaires elle a
baissé les taxes des entreprises
choisies des créneaux précis s'est
concentré sur les télécommunications et
les biotechnologies
il va falloir faire des choix ça va
prendre des priorités on ne relance pas
une ville en s'éparpillant dans toutes
les directions
manchester a cherché et trouvé des
milliards pour se refaire une beauté des
intérêts privés comme le club de soccer
ont financé des infrastructures
c'est pas juste de remettre en état
c'est qu'ils sont détériorées mais de
compléter les dispositifs de transport
en commun
bmo groupe financier et le boston
consulting group n'identifie toutefois
pas les créneaux sur lesquels mise et ce
sera aux élus et aux montréalais à
trouver tout ça ne se fera pas
rapidement les villes citées en exemple
ont pris au moins sept ans pour se
relancer
et françois lemaire coderre qui était à
ottawa aujourd'hui
ouais il y est toujours d'ailleurs parce
que demain se réunissent les maires des
grandes villes canadiennes mais il est
passé par un endroit aujourd'hui qu'il
connaît bien il était visiblement
heureux d'y être la chambre des communes
donc le parlement canadien il a
d'ailleurs des rencontres aujourd'hui
rencontre avec le ministre christian
paradis rencontre aussi avec le ministre
denis lebel n'a pas voulu trop nous dire
s'il sera question du pont champlain dit
que c'est pas l'unique sujet sur lequel
il va parler
il va parler aussi de postes canada
d'ailleurs on peut écouter monsieur
connaît très bien parlé de fausses
canada côté à quel point que sa proton
c'est le fait de couper la négation à
domicile ont reparlé de sécurité
ferroviaire on va parler de logement
parce que le gouvernement comptait des
fonds dans le logement puis on va parler
également de toute la nation monsieur
coderre nous dit qu'il va parler aussi
de son voyage à haïti parce qu'il s'en
va du côté d'haïti dans une semaine et
demie et vous savez ils devaient
rencontrer dans ce voyage en fait il
essayait de rencontrer le premier
ministre stephen harper il l'avait
d'ailleurs annoncé mais visiblement le
bureau du premier ministre n'avait pas
apprécié et donc il n'y aura pas de
rencontre entre le secondaire et le
premier ministre harper on nous dit que
ce sera remis à une prochaine fois mais
parions que le pont champlain et son
péage ont bel et bien fait l'objet des
discussions assure m
salut françois hollande envoie